à à
anh alo alo cho các bạn
ừ ừ
anh alo alo
rồi chúc mừng năm mới các bạn
à à
anh
không biết các bạn thế nào nha mình thì
mình thích à à
cho mình được Cha Cố ngủ đến nỗi là mình
thích theo Tết âm là dễ Dương Dương thì
tôi tôi chỉ hào hứng về cái vụ đi Xem
bản xem đã đếm ngược cả là với cái thời
đấy ở Hà Nội nó có đếm ngược của
Heineken giá cả máy cái gì gì đó nó cả
nhạc sôi động các sư dư tôi đi đầy đúng
là trên lấn xô đẩy thật nhưng mà
nhằm mà nó có không khí và nhưng mà tội
chẳng có rượu bia gì cả mang tiếng Anh
đi rửa 20cen chẳng ốm hội bia rượu gì cả
Có chỉ đi nhảy mệt kẹo Nghe nhạc DJ giữ
sôi động nhưng mà mấy năm nay thì không
đi nữa rồi nghe Thực ra là hôm qua mình
vừa đón giao thừa bằng cách gà ngồi chơi
nhân phẩm
còn chẳng biết Giao Thừa Đã Qua à à
chợ Tết âm này nó mới có không khí chứ
không ạ ạ thế âm hồi bể ngay từ hồi bé
kiểu Tôi ở Dinh dưỡng kiểu đội để được
lì xì đợi để được chúc xong rồi gặp
người thân trong gia đình của kìa Thực
sự thì không biết gia đình các bạn thế
nào nhưng mà người thân trong gia đình
tôi thì chắc chỉ có một vài dịch trong 5
ngày mới mới gặp nhau còn không thì cũng
kiểu kiểu cho dù nhà gần nữa Chẳng vỡ
chẳng bờ lên Nói tiếp xúc thì chả ai có
việc rồi đấy không ạ
à À quên tắm tranh thủ tâm sự một tí thì
mình cho các bạn xem cái video này
thời gian mình mới xem lại các bạn nghĩ
gì Xem cái video này nhé
các video về hay gặp nhau cuối tuần cho
có bạn xem rồi
Ừ thế cũng được chứ anh là ừ em là nhà
nghiên cứu tại sao thì được thưởng
100.000 trong khi những người khác không
làm gì Lại thưởng chịu nọ chỗ kia là do
giọng nói trên cũng chả hiểu luôn để tôi
giải thích cho rõ ràng nhé Bây giờ tôi
nói đặt giả dụ như là trại gà và chúng
ta tôi nói ví như là cái cây này tôi hỏi
cậu thế Bây giờ tôi là cái đoạn nào của
giám đốc thì chắc là gốc rễ rồi Đúng rồi
giám đốc là gốc rễ là tôi nhé Tôi ngồi
đây đúng không Thế bây giờ trên thân cây
này là các phó giám đốc Đúng không các
trưởng phó vòng là tất càng lớn này đấy
chứ có mập các cành nhỏ đây
là các cán bộ công tác lâu năm có thâm
niên
Em năm nay mới nhậu thì là ở đâu là tụi
em thì chắc là lá rất chính xác suất
chính xác cậu là lá cây đấy cho thấy cho
nhân viên mới là lá cây Thế bây giờ đặt
giả thiết bốn trăm bó với chơi này thì
mới ta phải làm gì mang nước đến cưới
của gốc cây đúng cho namnước đến tới mà
đừng nói giả dụ như cái việc tiền thưởng
như là mình lấy nước mình tới và cay Thế
thì mình cưới với tế bào dễ này Đây là
dễ đây anh nhá Ờ ở đây đúng không
nước tưới và dễ liên tưởng chữ vào đây
thì vào đây thì tôi sẽ hút toàn bộ cái
lúc này tôi chuyển lên cho bắt giám đốc
phó giám đốc đúng không bao giờ nó phải
chuyển các cảng lớn chỉ là cái lớn đúng
không làm tranh lớn lại chuyển lên các
cán bộ trắc cán bộ lâu năm thành nhỏ vào
cái lá này thì bây giờ cái lá là muốn
tươi thì ta chỉ nghịch quẩy vài giọt
nước của tôi chưa bao giờ buồn nếu mà
Vậy toàn bộ vào nó trêu thì mình mua
ở đâu
Anh nói chị đấy mà chúng Thôi em không
dám bì tị mấy trưởng phó phòng đừng cơm
đốc rồi nhưng mà anh đơn thử Ánh lần làm
lành cũng là lá nhé em nhân viên tại sao
mà anh được thưởng mấy triệu trong khi
ăn được thưởng 100.000 đ
anh Lâm có thâm niên công tác lâu năm
rồi bao năm mới ngồi trên ngọn đây rồi
Bây giờ anh mới xu U20
Thế bây giờ nhánh cây thì bây giờ anh
xuống lên cây anh nhánh cây mới được
thưởng nhiều hơn lá bây giờ không có cái
nhanh kênh thì là 2.000 cậu nó bám ở đâu
đấy chả ra một chút tâm chết được
Nghĩ sao một tí nữa
không phải nghĩ ra một tí
của Hoàng giám đốc em cũng có điểm gì mà
lại trừ lương em ạ Đêm hôm nọ thưởng có
nhận không có thì có nhận thì bây giờ
được làm ăn thua lỗ thì tất cả của mình
trừ lương thì sao lại về kêu mà tại sao
cho nó em đã nói với cả giám đốc rồi hợp
đồng với rất mù mờ không khả thi đâu anh
em không tham gia thực hiện hợp đồng đấy
Em không có lỗi tôi không bảo cậu có lỗi
không ai có lỗi hết lỗi là nỗi Nói chung
không ai có lỗi cả tất cả mọi người đều
bị trừ bữa anh làm sao đây mình còn kêu
cực kêu ca đi làm chưa giám đốc là hôm
nọ anh có nói chuyện với cái Cây Kơ hôm
nay trừ lương sẽ không chửi đâu cái công
chức của cái cây đúng là cậu nhắc cái
cây tung nhớ đây tôi vẫn còn nguyên tôi
chưa xóa đâu Đây
trại gà của chúng ta như cái cây này
được mất tiền thường rót vào được đưa
tới cây Thế bây giờ mà làm ăn thua lỗ
thì như là gió bão gió bão quật vào kênh
nhá Khi là tôi hỏi cậu khi cho bão quật
một cây thì cay trên một cây này thì cứ
bộ phận nào là chụp ảnh hưởng nặng nề
nữa
cành lá đúng rồi Kênh lá canh lá chịu
ảnh hưởng nặng nề nhất đúng không gặp
tôi đây này là gốc rễ này Đấy gió thổi
vào chỉ vào tỉnh nã vào canh vào cây chứ
có bao giờ vào gốc thế mà tôi vẫn chịu
đóng ô tô bao giờ kêu ca đâu đấy Đừng
nói là có biết nghe gió còn bay lá cây
gió quật gãy cành Nhỏ do cần cây càng
lớn hay là đồ cả thân cây nhưng mà cái
không Vẫn còn kiên gốc rễ để vẫn còn thì
sau này mầm cây này đúng lên
có thấy tất cả ngoài đường mùa giông bão
một trang điều tự phạt hết cả cành lá để
cứu cả thân cây thêm những cơ quan mình
sống với nhau có tình không hả như thế
cũng được
nên em hiểu đó thôi
cơm đâu
này mà cậu cố gắng lên một chút đi Cố
gắng cống hiến nhiều lắm à Tôi nghĩ rằng
làm ơi năm nữa có khi cậu cũng thành một
nhánh nhỏ đấy nhỉ Vợ tai nghe cho em gửi
cái này cái gì đấy đơn xin nghỉ việc Tố
tụng xác định này Hoàng ơi
cái đùa thôi đơn vị cũ đang làm dự án
nghiên cứu gà sách vẫn đang nghỉ việc
chỗ nào thì có cái gì đâu ạ cứ anh cứ
phân công cho thân cây với cả cành cây
nghiên cứu còn em thôi OK hay Hoàng Cậu
còn tương lai gì
300 như không không phải càng thêm nhanh
cây gì cả Cậu còn tương lai tôi cậu
không thích nói đến cây đúng không Thì
tôi Lấy một ví dụ khác nhau Ví dụ như
trại gà Chúng ta đang như một con thuyền
vượt đại dương một con thuyền đi vòng
cái được thủng một lỗ tất cả không xuống
cho vào top những cái đi chết chìm biết
đâu nhưng mà tôi thôi cố gắng đi tôi
biết là cậu cống hiến rất nhiều và mọi
người sẽ đều có thường thường khoản
chúng ta tất cả đều là của chung nha cố
điện thoại nhé
Cảm ơn anh Ok Ngoan quá nơi ở
thì các bạn đúc kết được gì từ tế từ
phẩm Hà để hi vọng không ăn gậy thì da
Mình thấy nhiều nhiều nó đang ngồi mình
còn định chia sẻ video với táo quân rồi
nhưng mà chắc là Táo Quân thì em Gợi hơn
còn đi theo kia tiểu thì phẩm cũ rồi chứ
không ngồi đấy chắc là không khái niệm
về bản quyền để đánh bật tiền đâu ạ
Nghe ca cổ khi ở tôi hôm nào tôi thở
livestream mà để chế độ à
anh
để chế độ về kiểu dạng là ở đây nó có 3
chế độ một lời chế độ
Anh bình thường hay chế độ kéo
có thêm tí và 3 lực không không thể gặp
những kiểu trễ dẫn ít cái chữ rất ít thì
được là về độ phân giải của cái video nó
sẽ không được nét lắm bởi vì mình dậy
cốt mình không muốn các bạn nhìn cốt
kiểu chữ bị mờ với gì cả chất lượng với
nét nên thành ra mình để chế độ trễ chắc
là tâm về trễ phải 20 30 giây gì đó nên
thành ra là một lúc sau mới thấy được
bình luận
mọi người có khuya nói gì cũng đúng
không ạ
300 cái video vừa rồi nó đương nhiên là
bạn thấy bạn để bạn thấy ông già nước
văn vở đúng
Ừ ông ấy nói trước gạo có cái lý của nó
là phải có trên có dưới có cái lý thôi
tình Chắc là mất rồi nhưng mà nó không
áp dụng được Quan trọng là nó không áp
dụng được vào trong cái việc à
Mày toàn con người chống lại với mất cái
tình mất rồi
ừ ừ
à à
chào các bạn đây vẫn mẹ chưa on hết nhỉ
chạm Nếu mà cái video vừa rồi thì mình
đúc kết thì nó sẽ là
nó nó là bài toán
vẫn vẫn là thực lại vẫn có thực tại vẫn
khó cho rồi đấy video rất rất lâu rồi
mình thích Cái hài mẹ kế hài châm biếm
người thế
Từ từ lâu rồi nhưng mà nó vẫn kiểu nó
vẫn phản ánh đúng được tại và các vận
chuyển của tương lai nãy
kiểu mình thấy rất hay sẽ lâu xem lại
vẫn thấy nó vẫn tâm đắc là đúng
ừ ừ
Ừ mình Hi vọng mùa hè đó mình kéo Xem
lại những cái video điển hình về giá
Quân huy các thứ
thì lúc đấy mình chỉ kiểu cười và trái à
may mà nó đã qua rồi Làm kiểu đại dịch
này là Nhạn hi vọng Hoàng kéo năm nay
hoặc thực ra là
ờ ờ để mà chấm dứt được nó là đại dịch
thì có thể
a
hoàn toàn thể xảy ra được trong năm nay
bởi vì bây giờ tiêm chủng các thứ ổn tôi
nhưng mà còn để mà không không bao giờ
xuất hiện còn víu để nữa hay ở không
được số điện còn vì tương tự và văn điều
đấy điều không thể gửi Thứ nhất Nó virus
gây Út Tất cả chỉ là sẽ luôn phát triển
nó sẽ kiểu không ngừng kiểu tiến hóa là
tiền hóa nhanh hơn con người rất nhiều
nên mình phải chạy đua y học với nó
anh sẽ không bao giờ có khái niệm mà
không bao giờ có loại virus đấy nữa hay
là không có loại virus khác
anh kể về sinh học thôi
đấy thì
Ừ
tự nhiên mình người sau Vios đang chủ đề
về gì nhỉ Ừ nhưng mà đại khái là hi vọng
là à về sau mình xem lại nhưng cả Táo
Quân
năm cũ thì mình sẽ chỉ cười kiểu dạng mà
Ừ Ít ra nó đã qua rồi nó gọi chứ không
phải là vẫn còn nhức nhối như hiện tại
à à
Ừ thứ hai là đấy cũng là một cái khái
niệm của tự nhiên thôi Như à Nhờ chồng
chết học mà cái cái gì Đói thì quy luật
của tự nhiên thì nó sẽ độc hại những cái
gì đó kiểu không thích nghi được
Anh không dùng từ không thích nghi được
chứ không phải sống ngu dùng từ ngu thì
chết hay là đen đen thôi hai cái gì đó
không không khái niệm đấy chuyển ra là
không thích nghi được không thích nghi
kịp thì sẽ bị đào thải
anh có thể bởi vì mình không thể nói rõ
ràng Phương ngu thì chết biết đâu rồi về
sau người thân hệ người thân mình giận
chính bản thân mình cũng có thể ngoại
Ê mày về ông mà còn Mạnh mồm bây giờ
nhiệm mẹ mồm xong người kiểu bị dính bị
báo bóc
cho
nên đại khái thế nó kiểu các bạn xem hài
châm biếm thì có bạn sẽ nên đúc kết được
nhiều cái không ạ nhé còn từ cái video
rồi thì mình muốn nói là cái á Ừ cái đấy
mình nói ở hiện tại vẫn còn nhưng nghĩ
ra Đỡ hơn và biệt trong ngành công nghệ
công ty này
chị số ít công ty là nó không trọng dụng
các bạn còn đâu thì từ nhân viên mới
nhưng mà các bạn đã có chí các bạn làm
tốt các bạn thăng tiến rất là nhanh và
cũng ngược lại là nó hơi bị dở hơi bị
buồn phải nói dùng tới biện buồn bờ phía
giả sử như trong video về rồi là các
Like là cá ra cái gì À các nhân viên lâu
năm nó ngoãn thâm niên thì cũng sẽ bị ở
lại Nếu thực sự là họ hết năng lực Họ
không làm được theo kịp bởi vì công ty
công nghệ sĩ đào thải nó sẽ rất nhanh nó
không thể theo lùng như cái cây giống
như cái video rồi đèo ngoạn nó giống cái
thiết mà vừa rồi nó chọn lọc tự nhiên
hơn đấy có ai mà không thích nghi kịp sẽ
bị đào thải
Ừ thì thì công ty công nghệ nó sẽ thế
nghĩa là không phải
vừa vừa định nghi về công nghệ mới vừa
phải nâng cao kiến thức hơn để nhặt củ
bám lấy công ty hay gì gì đó
mà thứ là còn để mà mức lương phù hợp
hơn các thứ thứ Nếu sử mà thầy lương
không xứng đáng để mình còn nhảy việc
sang công ty khác như công ty đối thủ cơ
toàn thường anh xem công ty đối thủ của
lương cao hơn
Hà Nội dung vào ngành Công nghệ thông
tin này mình thấy là nó vừa xuống thế
nhưng mà nó cũng và thách thức kiểu để
mà ai cũng phải nhìn nhận lại phấn đấu
nó khác với nhiều ngành nghề khác cực Nó
là kiểu các bạn có làm lâu năm thì các
bạn sẽ giữ được cái ghế đấy hả lương nó
sẽ cao hơn không khác hoàn toàn
cho nên nó thách thức cái kiểu các bạn
phải chứng tỏ được mình
mình nói thế nhưng mà thứ ra mình có
phải con nên người ta nên là mình đang
đi lên một cách từ từ Và đôi lúc thì dậm
chân tại chỗ Tiến hình gần đây mình bận
dậy nè sau đó thì mình làm việc
thời gian rảnh ngồi chơi không Không cho
dồi thêm kiến thức mới mình chỉ Cốt lại
những cái thứ mình đã biết còn lại những
cái đoạn mình đã cốt ông ạ thì mình
không gọi là mình đang cốt cứng tay chứ
không phải là là kiểu mình là developer
là nhà phát triển là ngày ngày càng Khả
cốt khá hơn cũ Vì thế nên là
Vì thế nên là ở mình đang bị chậm lại
anh không ạ thử cái như mình đã nói
không biết mình nói các bạn về cái vụ là
nhiều nhà Tiến Dũng nhiều hát rồi rồi mà
không biết về công nghệ công ty Ý và
đánh giá các bạn qua về cái CV các bạn
về bằng cấp 2 có người gửi thì để những
hang Tôi dùng tồi bởi họ không thực sự
hiểu về quy trình Cái ngành này còn nếu
mà một nhà Tuyển dụng chuẩn họ đánh giá
các bạn đã làm những cái gì Thể hiện đam
mê như thế nào
có khoảng chứ không phải đã qua kỷ niện
đến như là thí nghiệm kinh nghiệm làm
cái thôi nhưng mà ý là không phải qua
kinh nghiệm đã làm ở bao nhiêu công ty
đã làm công ty lớn như nào với Vân Đồn
hạ mình thực ra mình không thích một cái
CV của một người
làm ví dụ là
ở gần đây do mình không biết nói thế
xong rồi cậu bị có bị à sự nghiệp quá
không phải dùng từ người quét có bị à
có thể dùng từ như nào nhỉ nói tôi nói
xong rồi sợ là Kiều mày nữa Thấy người
ta tốt thật chắc là tội xấu hổ lắm nhưng
mà người mới vào công ty của tôi ờ
có cái CV nó phải rất hoành tráng anh ấy
lớn hơn tôi một tuổi ở với nhau Tôi
không chỉ đích danh được với cả thì mọi
không biết gì cả đâu nhưng mà nói chung
là anh đấy thời làm rất nhiều công ty
khoe rất nhiều dự án nghiên cứu rất đầu
kia Thực ra thì tôi thấy tôi từng nói
rồi mà tự thức là nhiều hl thấy đấy mà
ấn tượng tốt tôi thì không về thấy giống
như kiểu một người nghỉ việc quá nhiều
lần kiểu
A lô tô 1 tuổi mà đi đi học ở đại học
chính quy thì sẽ sẵn là ra trường muộn
hơn tôi có thể đi làm ngay thời ở trên
trường rồi nhưng mà thấy kiểu bảy tám
con ty gì ấy sau đó gì à
à Còn cái cái việc mà tôi đã từng nhắc
mấy bạn vừa khi viết cv đó là không bao
giờ nên đánh giá điểm
có kỹ năng của mình bởi vì điểm kỹ năng
đấy nó không hề trên một cái thước đo gì
cả hạn chế cái việc đấy Hồi trước bị
từng tự đánh giá mình trên cái thang
điểm đấy về sau mình phải loại đi Mình
chỉ cần thật ra là các bạn không cần
phải ghi luôn kỹ năng mình cần có những
đã có những cái gì ngoài ngoại ngữ thực
sự như thế nếu các bạn với ngoại ngữ thì
các bạn chứ đi vào là biết ngoại ngữ vi
giao tiếp để những cái những kỹ năng mà
kỹ năng gọi là kỹ năng khác ở trong cây
ở trong gan lĩnh vực của bạn đây mình
cho các bạn xem lại nhắc Thế để bạn sẽ
hình dung hơn mình cho các bạn xem lại
được seri của chính mình
mình không phải khoe đâu người mình từng
nói rồi Nhưng mà thực sự thì ạ
Mình cảm thấy là anh có nhiều bạn
dùng cái mẫu template đấy nó bị dính rồi
đấy mình làm cái này bằng word Quấy mình
tự đánh dán cái trình độ của mình toàn
kể trên thang điểm tối đa kiểu như này
để tối đa đối với bản thân mình nghe
mình khá nhất về các lĩnh vực đấy nhưng
mà cứ viết tháng điểm tối đa là nhiều
người sẽ hiểu nhà màu với ông này chắc
phải thành chuyến ra rồi à
Em mà về sau thì mình loại cả đấy đi
khỏi thì phim gần đây nhất của mình
Ờ Ờ
mình không hề ghi gì không Không hề ghi
kiểu mình biết vì ngôn ngữ nào ở đây cả
mà mà trong kinh nghiệm làm việc của
mình thôi à Có dụng công nghệ rồi thì
kiểu gì người ta sẽ biết được là mình
biết mình những cái lý rồi tự nhiên
người ta sẽ phải đặt đó Ngoại còn ở trên
này thì mình chỉ có giới thiệu bản thân
và có kỹ năng giao tiếp và thuyết trình
chẳng hạn đấy và biết ngôn ngữ ở bên
ngoại ngữ cảnh thế được rồi
các bạn sẽ không cần phải có hạng mục
riêng giống như hồi đây những kỹ năng
này mình để mục riêng như này ra cái
thang điểm này chẳng biết đánh giá trên
cái gì Chắc đánh giá trên bản thân thôi
đánh giá được chuyện gì
thì tại sao tự nhiên mình đã nói vụ đấy
bởi vì a thậm chí chính mình còn không
tự đánh giá được bản thân mình còn trên
thang điểm tối đa Thế mà người ông mới
vào bên công ty thôi Cái gì ông ấy mời
nhưng 13 cái 10 nhân 10 cái tên 10 trên
10 giờ
Lê Văn học văn phòng
tin học văn phòng mới trên 10 rồi ral 19
10 nó không hiểu ông ấy tin học văn
phòng 10 trên 10 thì ông ấy sẽ
chị sẽ là gì xô la em ở trên 10 sang
toàn bộ tài liệu của lá nào trong người
thuộc lòng hết rồi
Ừ cái điều đấy gà tôi thấy nó cứ bị sao
ấy nhỉ
Ừ ông nghe cái việc hẳn một cái quên gốc
mà ông được 10 X10 thì nó là trên thang
điểm gì nghe nó cứ tốn không ạ
Ừ ừ thì cho biết là người ta có thể Cái
này ra kiểu có thể là kiểu án chỉ thả
mình rất tự tin thì cái việc này đúng
nhưng mà Thu bảo với thử cơ à Chỉ cần
qua kinh nghiệm của ông thôi Ông ấy còn
ghi kinh nghiệm bản thân tôi bảo rồi làm
việc 7 8 công ty
Ừ rồi xong rồi cô nghĩ công ty để ông đi
hết toàn bộ công nghệ da xịn vãi không
biết là ông ấy có động hết rồi toàn bộ
không ấy Không phải ghi hết ra sau rồi
phần Kỹ nào Âu cũng đi hết còn 10:10 còn
nói chúng mày chẳng có điểm nào dưới 70
toàn 78 toàn 8 9 10
Ừ tớ thế là cậu
ở một vài công ty tuyển được siêu nhân
hay là
có một người mà chưa quay Lãng nổ hi
vọng cốt của ông ấy không thể hiện mình
à
sự nguy hiểm một vì cốt thì được ca là ở
trường ca thì cái khái niệm này nó là
như thế này Khái niệm và mình không biết
bình thường nói các bạn chưa về cài
còn những kiểu lập trình viên
kia đổi kiểu một nào kiểu mới học Nhập
Môn thì các bạn chưa biết cốt các bạn
cũng sẽ rất là chậm và các bạn cốt sẽ
đợi có thể sinh đầy lỗi mặt là thứ của
vì các bạn chưa truyền các bạn chưa ra
đất chưa kiểm tra gì cả Ờ đấy Gọi Junior
gọi là năm đầu còn Suneo là 52 đến 53 gì
đó nếu đề các bạn biết cốt rồi
thì các bạn ngựa non háu đá Các bạn cứ
thấy có một cái gì đó ngầu ngồi trên
mạng các bạn copy về cốt sau đó thì cốt
muốn cho ngắn nhất có thể để mà kiểu
trong ngầu kiểu ba bốn nòng cốt chạy
được đấy cốt kiểu đấy là cốt kiểu của
tôi vì sao với người khác đọc chẳng hiểu
cái gì cả và ngựa non khấu hao đá mà nên
thành ra lại đến ham cốt cột nhanh hơn
cả đảo
tay nhanh hơn nào đây đúng không ạ
A và phải đến và nhiều người được đến
gọi là 23 năm ấy ông nhưng nhiều người
còn kéo dài cái cái soohyo lấy dài hơn
cơ đâm chỉ là về sau vẫn mẹ nó ra như
thế phải đến khi nào mà các bạn nghĩ kỹ
trước khi cốt truyện Nói chung là hư giờ
xử đến
54 55 đi thì nghỉ chị Nghị kỹ chứ Khi
cốt vừa gì đó và cốt sẽ rất là có thể là
dai không một tí nhưng mà tối ưu hơn và
nó sẽ dễ hiểu hơn người khác đọc cái
hình dung ngay ở đoạn này làm gì người
ta người ta bỏ cốt xịn là cốt mà không
cần phải chú thích mà đọc qua thì cô đã
hiểu rồi không cần phải Chú thích gì cả
anh đấy à
à à
Ừ đúng rồi thực ra là ờ
Ừ mình cảm thấy về sau mình trưởng thành
hơn mình không cần phải khoe mẹ nhiều
nữa cho mình sẽ bỏ ra còn họ thì chắc là
họ có thể là do là họ đang muốn tìm kiếm
một công ty một cách kiểu khá thiết tha
hoặc cả nói chung và vẫn có tí mình mình
được dùng từ vẫn đúng đó là khoe mẽ rồi
đấy những cái thành tựu của mình thực ra
là khoe thì không có gì sai cả Không ạ
nhưng mà
cái việc khoe
anh tự đánh giá được đúng thì thì không
xa đúng ạ tự tin khác với tự đại kiểu
phóng lại bản thân mình lên nếu các bạn
đấy tự tin mà làm được thì chẳng ai kiểu
chẳng ai thể trên sách được đầy ngoạn
nhưng mà nhưng mà đừng có bị xa quá như
tôi đã nói là tôi biết đâu đấy hôm hôm
nay nói thế xong rồi về sau thấy bạn ấy
cốt ngon lành thì có vẻ ổn thì mình lại
lúc đấy chắc là mình biến thành một cái
thằng kiểu vậy Nhà Việt Nam thức ở Chắc
thế
Ừ nhưng mà thực ra là có những cái điều
mà tôi đang chia sẻ thế với mấy ông ở để
mấy ông tự rút kinh nghiệm đó là không
không không nên kiểu ghi hẳn như thế kể
cả khi mình đã thành công với được là
khi em thành công hồi ông chả cần ghi
giống như tôi với cái CV lên đấy ra
nhiều nhiều người biết đến tôi trước khi
ở biết là sim gì vô rồi
Ừ đấy thì như mình vừa nói tôi đã không
cần nói đôi khi không cần chú thích mà
Đọc cốt vẫn hiểu thì nó mới tốt
Khi dòng máy tốt cho người khác không
phải bây giờ ông già sửa ông cốt 50 dòng
sông phải thực ra chẳng ai hiểu ga 50
vòng đấy số người chú thích hơn 30 dòng
nữa để giải thích mỗi dòng ông mẹ là
phải giải thích lại xem cái đoạn này cốc
cái gì thì người ta một lờ lực lập trình
viên khi mà nhìn vào
sẽ thấy chán mọi người ngoài nhỉ Người
Ngọ không không nói ngoài nhưng mà nói
chúng con nhìn rồi Đúng đấy nó dễ chán
Hay vì ông cố tận 100g như dòng đọc cái
hiểu luôn thì ra đôi khi không cần 100
lòng đâu
con gà Nếu mà về sau các bạn làm cốt
chuẩn chuyên nghiệp có dưới chia nhỏ
những cái này ra là những cái gọi là
môđun là những cái tính năng nhỏ dụng ở
tính năng kết nối giống như hồi trước ạ
Hôm trước mình dậy các bạn là chưa nhỏ
ra lại là file nào Phai kết nối thanh
niên 1 file file nào phải kiểm tra kiểm
tra đăng nhập thì các em mua riêng một
file không ạ thì các bạn chỉ cần nhìn
nhìn qua tên file bạn hiểu được à chai
này để làm tính năng này pha lại chỉ làm
tính năng này nhìn và bật là ngày đúng
không ạ số ngồi có cái file
chỉ cần kết nối wi-fi kia thì chỉ cần
vui quay kiểu bị chèn nó thêm vào thôi
đúng ạ Đấy thì người ta nhìn thấy bất
ngờ ngay đấy
chú ý mình là như thế nói chỉ là cốt sao
cho mà không cần chú thích vẫn hiểu được
đấy mới lạ có chị ạ
à à
Em
chưa có kinh nghiệm với cv kiểu gì thì
mình từng có nói qua vụ đấy Đó là bạn
thực ra là rất khó để mà kiểu bát các
bạn chỉ ghi một cái simbi quá ngắn đeo
kiểu giới thiệu bản thân thôi tự nhiên
các bạn đôi khi phải chèn thêm kỹ năng
của việc ra các bạn chưa có gì Khoe
Nhưng mà đấy là lý do mà mình bảo là các
bạn sẽ phải làm thêm gửi vài cái dự án
ngoài nếu do sự mà cậu các bạn là chưa
có bài tập lớn ở trên trường giống như
cái đồ án của mình đang dậy thì các bạn
nên làm tự làm thêm dự án để mà có thứ
được khỏe và các bạn nói là các bạn áp
dụng công nghệ gì trong đấy chứ còn
không thì không thì con không thì đừng
ra năm sau đánh giá được các bạn qua cái
gì có cái ảnh các bạn ạ Hai qua các bạn
trình bày cv trong đẹp như thế nào không
ạ
à à
Ừ
Ok Sao Bây giờ mình sẽ tâm sự nói về cái
đồ án trước khi mình mình chuyển qua Mở
tất cả các đồ ăn các nhóm để mà lên chấm
ông ạ Có nhiều nhiều nhóm ở đây sẽ có
mặt rồi
thì thực là đến ngày hôm qua vẫn có
người nhắn tin cho mình là đúng rồi
record mà bạn kiêng nhắc mình nhớ mình
quên đấy Mình sẽ ở mình sẽ dậy ở really
và Isaac
à quên quên bảo sao tự nhiên mình thấy
thiếu thiếu rõ ràng hoàn toàn với hình
dạng được cái đấy trong phần nâng cao ở
Serie A
ở Iraq
Anh Dương cái này thì kiểu gì mình sẽ
dạy các bạn bởi vì sao Bởi vì à
đương nhiên là những cái này nó là Ê
công nghệ cũ lỗi thời rồi không ít công
ty áp dụng nhưng mà dạy qua cái này để
các bạn hình dung qua được và các bạn
hoàn toàn mới hệ xử lý ở bên phía người
dùng được khách hàng thay vì kiểu cứ
phải kiểu tải lại trang để ở tp xử lý
thì các bạn sẽ thấy à
để tui ở công nghệ này chưa công nghệ cũ
nhưng mà hoàn toàn là cái
cách nó vận hành cách nó hoạt động thì
nó vẫn thế với nó vẫn là g-switch Lê
Hoàn toàn vẫn dậy được thưởng ngoạn ok
ờ ờ
ở đấy thì về cái đồ án thì đến ngày hôm
qua thì vẫn có người xin nghỉ mình Mình
thấy hơi bị buồn và cũng hơi bị ngạc
nhiên một tí bởi vì thì da mình có nói
với ban cán bộ đó là ở
à mình mình thường ơ lo việc là các bạn
sẽ nghỉ suy nghĩ nhiều ở đầu lúc mà mới
đăng ký mới đăng ký xong đôi khi ạ Ông
vừa đăng ký xong rồi ông sẽ cần nhắc rút
lại còn dưỡng hay thế cái thằng kia nó
bị tâm lý đó sau đó thì thực ra đến gần
cuối của cái gần hôm bảo vệ mấy ông cũng
có thể sinh nghi với mấy ông sợ đã áp
lực quá sợ không theo kịp các bạn Vân
còn bây giờ ở đoạn giữa đấy Thực ra các
bạn đang nằm rồi 10 chương với các bạn
đôi khi ngại bỏ mọi gì đó Nếu hôm qua
vẫn có người bỏ mình nghĩ một phần là có
thể do các bạn bị bận đương nhiên các
bạn chắc chắn bị bật rồi vì nhiều bạn ở
đây
em
không học không học theo ngành này và
đặc biệt hơn nữa đó là mình không phải
là thầy cô dạy trực tiếp quá bạn ở trên
trường nó khác với sinh viên cũ của mình
sinh viên cũ của mình sẽ rất sợ bị mình
đã gạch tên khỏi đồ án vì bạn đấy Kiểu
gì bạn đấy dù bạn không theo ngày này
bạn vẫn muốn lấy cái bằng bạn hãy kiểu
gì vẫn phải cố làm kế toán thì có cái
bang thế là sinh viên mình rất sợ điều
đấy thế nên là mình mới loại bỏ cái cột
Nếu các bạn để ý kĩ là mình đã loại bỏ
cái cột à
ở cột
cạnh cảnh cáo đấy mình chỉ còn cụ đánh
giá gần nhất thôi Bởi vì thực sự thì các
bạn đã không không sợ việc là mình loại
tên gọi đồ ăn cái gì đó
ý thức sữa như thế nó không có tí áp lực
lắm đấy nhớ các bạn không mất tiền đấy
thứ hai là các bạn đôi khi không theo
ngành này thứ Ba ở nhà mình có đánh
trượt các bạn hãy gì gì đó nữa thì nó
không phải là thứ
[âm nhạc]
không quan trọng quan trọng nhất ngay
bây giờ rồi các bạn rồi bây giờ các bạn
còn còn học trên trường làm việc có thứ
nữa ngoạn các bạn sẽ không bị áp lực
kiểu đấy
Vì thế nên làm
nhưng nhưng mà mình vẫn
do mình vẫn sẽ kỳ vọng vào những nhóm
mang theo Rất kì vọng bởi những nhóm
mang theo Bây giờ họ hoàn toàn là kiểu
ra tâm huyết và rất là kiểu nghiêm túc
cho dù mình biết được có rất nhiều bạn
có hoàn cảnh noi khó hoàn cảnh nhá Bởi
vì bạn ấy rồi nhắn tin cho mình xin nghỉ
sau đó đi mình có nói ra mình chồng động
viên thì lắm để mình mình mình lời vì
mình có tư duy ở cửa là kèo
họ có công việc thật thì được là mình
không là ép buộc không không không nên
nhiều kéo gì cả phụ tình yêu thôi không
mình đi kèm thì cả ở họ muốn đi họ sẽ đi
ông ạ
Ừ Ừ
nhưng mà sau đó thì họ vợ mấy ngày hôm
sau thì họ bảo họ thu xếp ổn mồi họ muốn
tiếp tục là đấy thế nên là mình cảm thấy
là có rất nhiều bạn thực sự là kiểu thấy
nó là một cái gì ở dưới nghiêm túc dù à
Như tôi đã nói khi mà bảo vệ thành công
xong thì ngoài việc các bạn thỏa mãn ra
thì có cái gì đâu không ạ gặp tôi à Vì
cà phê à Cái gì đó hay là tra được tôi
tặng cái tài liệu ngoạn Ngoài ra còn bị
gì đâu nữa đúng không Nghĩa là cái này ở
gần trưa về giá trị về các bạn Trân
trọng cái giá trị của cái cái đồ án này
hơn hơn là hơn là những cái đang sau nó
ở đằng sau đó thêm cái bằng cấp hay là
quà cáp gì đó giải thưởng gì đó không
em ạ Các bạn muốn tự xem khả năng của
mình để đâu không ạ
ờ ờ bà
Ừ Mình định nói gì Đồ ăn đấy à À đúng
rồi làm cái nữa nó được ra là
thì các bạn thấy hôm nay ngày mùng 1
tháng 1 thì ra thì chính là deride của
cái link đăng ký làm đồ ăn kia ra mình
có định đăng đăng về link đăng ký lấy
lên nhóm beauty beauty để cho nhiều
người có thể đăng ký nhiều người biết
đến kênh mình hơn như mình vậy thôi Vì
sao vậy Thực ra là mình đang có hai
chiều để nghĩ có một chiều thì là muốn
giúp thêm gọi dùng từ giúp bởi vì thời
ra mình sẽ không công thì ta dùng từ
giúp bạn đúng nghĩa là giúp thêm nhiều
bạn biết đứa thêm về ngành Công nghệ
thông tin này à và
cho các bạn thử sức các thứ thứ ngoại
những một phần thì lại nghĩ rằng là
Ờ Ờ
mình kham nhiều quá thứ nhất là làm việc
cho mình theo kiểu là đấy thì bây giờ
tôi vẫn chấm tôi không chấm hết một đợt
mất cũng 23 tiếng sau đó đi ỉa
nhiều nhóm con bị thiếu nhiều nhóm cũng
bị thiếu ngân hàng ra là tôi phải nhắn
tin sau đó ngày hôm sau bạn ấy trả lời
cho ngày ông sao bạn em lại bảo tôi chấm
lại đấy thành ra là tuy gọi là bọn chấm
một ngày như ra nó bị đây thề dài tận
mấy ngày sau nếu không hiểu không ạ Đấy
là mới chỉ có mang tiếng gọi ba mấy nhóm
thực ra là có vài nhóm bị trừ mà đúng ạ
thật là bây giờ chẳng biết còn bao nhiêu
nhậu Tôi cho ông sẽ xem thực tế nhé Xem
có bao nhiêu nhóm đứa con nhé
Khi
chính người này nhóm em không ạ
A và cái này còn chúng rong
có ai tôi thêm một cục nữa đấy đi
ừ ừ
à à
khi còn 25 nhóm
này còn hai nhóm nhóm
Vì sao tự nhiên có cái A đây này anh ấy
dễ con 24 nhóm
còn 24 nhóm thôi ông ạ 24 nhóm em Xuka
thì không biết được bây giờ có sử dụng
gì thêm không nữa
Em hãy tư nhóm cho ra là đủ áp lực theo
kiểu là bởi vì khi mà chấm đồ án của các
bạn ấy Thực ra là trong một buổi một
nhóm thì tầm mà đều thuyết trình là tầm
15 phút là ít nhất như kiểu định sẽ lớn
hơn nữa rồi tính một nhóm trà sữa một
nhóm mỗi giám phút nhé
à 24 nhóm
nó khá là ổn nhỉ Nó 6 tiếng ấy biết
không nhớ mình tôi chấm và liên tiếp
nhưng sẽ 6 điểm mấy ông ngồi xem
livestream của 6 tiếng đó Ừ thôi Tôi
không nghĩ rồi đấy ông ạ Tôi chắc chắn
nó sẽ phải chia nhiều Buổi rồi ông ạ
Nhưng mà kể ra nó vẫn 6 tiếng
Ừ nếu không hiểu gì không ạ
16 tiếng thì mà làm đấy chưa tính việc
là mấy ông nó nhiều hơn 15 phút
Ừ đúng ạ
từ lúc biết được hồi mà tôi trợ chấm
chấm như thế nhưng mà đi dạy thì một
tiếng tôi được bao tiền không
ngờ Mấy ông hiểu thì tôi không ạ Nghĩa
làm gì là nó có gì đó cũng Thời gian là
vàng bạc thì thôi thế
ờ ờ
cũng nhiều nhưng mà sẽ ra nếu mà
Ừ nếu mà nói nhiều thấy ra tôi cũng vui
thôi không nói thế làm chứ ở Thôi đợi
anh em nghỉ đi để tôi chấm lý thôi không
không phải như thế mà thực ra tôi đang
vui là theo kiểu là đi ra cũng được ăn
đấy nhóm nhưng mà tôi buồn nhưng mà giảm
bớt nhóm nói thế thì lại cũng
không phải là là bây giờ mình muốn đăng
muốn thêm nhiều nhóm đăng ký theo cậu
rất rất nhiều
anh bởi rất nhiều được gà là nó ngoài
việc ngoài việc là tôi phải chấm rất
nhiều nhóm ra
anh đi Dậy đi Dậy Hồi trước lương của
tôi còn Thế một tháng có thể lên 135
triệu bởi vì Hồi đấy tôi dậy à từ 8 giờ
sáng đến 9 rưỡi tối thường đấy nha Hồi
trưa tôi dậy từ 8 giờ đến 12 giờ thôi từ
1 rưỡi thì năm rưỡi sau đó thì
về sau là chiếu thầy dạy buổi tối cho
các lớp mà năm ký học bổ túc hoặc là học
à học kiểu của của Michael của mấy sinh
viên trường khác hoặc là mấy mấy người
muốn học ngành trái ngành công nghệ công
ty đi mua hoa muốn học nghề sang Trường
tôi học buổi tối thì thiếu thầy dạy đứng
dậy lúc đấy mà thơ ca là còn phải có kĩ
năng nữa đây là tôi được đứng dậy luôn
rồi đấy là từ 6 giờ đến
36 Giờ đúng nhỉ 6 rưỡi 6 giờ rưỡi đến 9
rưỡi đấy để 3 tiếng buổi tối nữa
về sau tôi dậy như thế từ thứ 2 đến thứ
7 và và
rất nhiều Hôm mất luôn cả cả sáng và cả
chiều chủ nhật để mà chấm đoán và không
phải tạm một tuần mà đương nhiên như
mình đã nói một lớp thì sẽ có dầm mười
mấy với nhóm và
mình dậy 6 lớp nên thành gà mất luôn rất
nhiều ngày chủ nhật liên tiếp
anh nói chung là kiểu kiểu khi mà làm
việc mệt như thế xong tối về chán
cho nên hàng a hội đây rồi muốn kiếm
nhiều vậy Chưa làm gì thế
ừ ừ
10 kiểu gì ông sẽ nói quá 15 phút thôi
tin tôi mấy ông mấy ông không không
chuyện nó ngắn hơn 15 phút đâu
à À đúng rồi sao mức lương của tôi hương
tôi lại lên hơn 35 triệu Thời đấy bởi vì
lương tôi về một giờ cao phết
anh ở đấy có nhận tôi phá xuất sắc và
kiểu
sinh hoạt theo giờ rất nhiều quá làm tôi
cậu bây giờ tôi sợ sinh hoạt theo giờ
giấc tới sợ tiếng chuông Cứ
gần ba năm như thế
à à
Ừ
ok hơi rahman quá rồi nhưng đại khái ý
mình thì nãy giờ mình sẽ đúc kết lại như
này nhá
chắc chắn hỏi nhờ chứ các bạn thuyết
trình xong chán chơi mình sẽ hỏi nữa
kiểu định sẽ quá thôi Ờ ờ
à đại Khải ý mình nãy giờ nói về cái đồ
cái đăng ký đó là hôm nay mình vẫn đang
mở kho đăng ký và thực ra là mình cũng
chỉ mong là thế em được cùng lắm là 5
đến 10 nhóm nữa thôi
Ừ Chứ không mong hơn không ông quá nhiều
bởi vì a bởi vì Thật ra Sam nhiều quá sợ
ở kiểu mình sẽ không chi tiết chú trọng
được bằng một nhóm
bởi vì giới hạn con người vẫn nó có hạn
có mỗi mình mình đang chậm thôi Nhưng
không ngờ ai chấm được đấy thành ra là
chắc phải tạm thế
cho những ai mà xem được video này về
sau thì thằng bạn mình nhưng mà chắc là
mình cũng sẽ mở lại cái việc là cho đăng
ký thêm một lần nữa nếu mà có lượng
người đăng ký Vẫn còn à Nói cho danh
lãng phí vì sẽ mở mà nhưng mà mình sẽ
Ừ mình nếu mà thêm được 12 10 10 nhóm đổ
lên nữa về sau thì mình sẽ
cho mình mình sẽ vẫn sẽ cho mở mở thêm
đợt để mà bảo vệ nữa Mở đợt bảo vệ thôi
chúng mình không chạy lại với những cái
dậy mình đã dậy rồi
Ừ đúng ạ
Bây giờ mày ông hình dung nhé bây giờ mở
đợt bảo vệ thì rằng ở tôi sẽ một là mất
vào buổi buổi livestream một người khác
hoặc là tôi phải livestream vào trong
ngày dậy thì những cái nhóm những cái
lớp mà mình đang dậy dụng lớp web nâng
cao là nó ngoan thì lại bị mất một buổi
Thế ra thì mình chỉ có muốn giới hạn
trong vòng tháng 3 là phải xong hết tất
cả bảo vệ của cái đợt 1 này rồi
ở những câu hỏi của các bạn Hiện tại thì
chắc là mình xin phép về buổi xong mình
trả lời nhé Bây giờ thì hơi bị buồn
8:30 sợ hôm nay chậm Chỉ lướt qua chấm
nước một tí thì da mình có chấm rồi nếu
các bạn để ý kĩ là mình chấm hết rồi bây
giờ mình sẽ cho các bạn gần như cháu bạn
xem qua thôi mình cho bạn xem qua để các
bạn ạ tự xem các nhóm khác đang như thế
nào thì hợp lý hơn phải dùng từ đấy nó
bị hơn
Ờ Ờ mấy câu hỏi này chắc buổi sau mình
trả lời nhá câu hỏi này là có gọi không
phải liên quan đoán với sau mình sẽ trả
lời
mình sẽ nói có ai về những cái này những
cái
mình góp ý các bạn nên là trọng Mình mới
nhóm mỗi nhóm nó đoán nghe nhá đó đầu
tiên là xuất file FBI chọn ra để mà mình
inbox vào dễ này cũng trước mình có làm
cái tung đấy tự động inbox đấy anh ra
mấy ông mà ở
cái Porsche là mà hiểu sai có thiếu thứ
thì nó sẽ bị lỗi hoặc sport tận 3 4 file
không được đúng không ạ Vậy con một file
Thôi cứ ai là các bạn nên đặt đã ta bây
nên thôi Nên là tên do ta bây là số nhóm
các bạn để mình à
ở bờ biển Còn trước là tung của mình tạo
tự động là tạo theo
Anh tên là số nhóm chứ không phải là tên
của nhóm các bạn đang lập theo tên mỗi
tên một kiểu này ra là lúc mà mà đôi khi
cũng có thể trùng bên nữa hãy hiểu tôi
không đặt tên là ta bây theo tên tên đề
tài các bạn chọn được
a tiếp theo là các bạn đến xuất cái Wow
ra có thêm có dữ liệu chuẩn và có thêm
dữ liệu nhé Hôm trước có ông export là
ta bây không có một cái dữ liệu gì đó
Chắc là chỉ mới cấu trúc thôi nhưng mà
thành ra là tôi lúc này tôi thử đăng
nhập đến admin có nhập được tôi cố thử
thách vào những công an được đơn vị là
không có không có một tài khoản nào để
đăng nhập đúng ạ Được không vào được ở
dốc sao rồi Kiểm tra mấy thế vợ phải và
sữa cốt để đăng nhập được vào thành công
thì các bạn nên có dữ liệu để mình xem
qua được Và khi có dữ liệu trong như thế
nào Vân nhé á anh nói chung à
các bạn làm xong thêm sửa xóa xong hết
rồi mà mạng xong lại code cho bay ra xa
ngồi xong sau đó thì Atlat nó lên ký
đúng ạ
a tiếp theo là vừa rồi mình nói là các
bạn làm xem thêm sữa xóa thì có có nghĩa
là làm cái bế bên phần biến amin không ạ
thì không có nghĩa là bạn bên khách hàng
thì sẽ ngồi chơi bạn cần làm đăng kí
đăng nhập đang sắp là
khi mà bạn ăn đi làm xong nha thêm sản
phẩm thì phải Porter bay để cho
để cho bạn bạn kia bạn inbox vào và bạn
đấy sẽ hiển thị sản phẩm nào trông như
thế nào đúng ạ Đấy và bạn bên khách hàng
vẫn phải làm ít nhất một
bảng CRD đầy đủ bàn đấy Đồ ngoại để mà
bạn ấy hiểu về cú pháp câu I Swear đầy
đủ tính năng xem thêm sửa xóa chứ không
phải là bên ăn mì làm hết đấy là thực ra
là còn thêm về việc là
sự
phân công công bằng hợp lý ở đấy Đó là
kiểu các bạn sẽ phải hiểu
tại sao mình dùng tử cung bằng
thi công bảng ở đây em chỉ là kiểu không
bằng với cả hạ trình độ hai người nếu
bạn kia giỏi cho là phải bạn ấy phải
kiên nhiều hơn một tí Ngoại bạn bạn
khiến rảnh rỗi hơn thì bạn kiếm ngời ra
đồng tí không ạ mình được mình không thể
biết được tất cả những cái điều đấy vì
thế các bạn mình bảo bị giới hạn việc
online ngay Mình không biết là hết cả
tính cách các bạn mình là phải biết được
tên các bạn đôi khi tôi còn chẳng biết
tên gì không Toàn Tập thiệu nickname mà
không ạ
Nên là thư ca các bạn hãy tự
[âm nhạc]
em tự chủ động với nhau vẫn là nhiều nó
khác với kiểu hồi tôi dậy trực tiếp trên
lớp rất nhiều trên lớp thì tôi còn kiểu
thuốc được từng ông biết được tính cách
từng ông biết là trình độ từng Ông còn
bây giờ tôi cá toàn bộ của tôi vẫn còn
đang hơi mù mờ mà thử đã không nhớ được
không thể nhớ hết được
a tiếp theo là không Cái tiêu chí chấm
giải thưởng ấy hơn là chấm Cái không
đúng lắm à Thế bây giờ là các bạn nên có
một file con ếch thôi có cho là do là
bạn cốt 1 loạn biến ăn mì của bạn với
khách hàng mình anh có tận 2 file kết
nối thậm chí Hôm trước có một ông Ông ấy
chơi rồi
em không có phải kết nối phải chưa ông
ấy kêu toàn bộ Cái gì liên quan đến xem
nên nói chung là liên quan đã tới Bây
giờ ông ấy lại gọi lại câu máy queo một
lần sợ vãi
mà Tại sao tôi biết được đấy bởi vì
đương nhiên là tôi phải vào sửa cái đã
kết nối đến DB để mà tôi chạy thử cốt
mấy ông mà nó không ạ xong rồi về sửa
rất nhiều file nhìn trong nhà nữa
Ẩm Thực ra tôi cũng nghĩ có thể làm tôn
để làm được đấy nhà đập tất cả code của
mấy ông sửa lại điều đấy nhưng mà thôi
không không phải cái gì An dụng tôi như
thế
các bài toán con người và có thể làm
được mà không ạ Con người cũng cũng phải
giải quyết vấn đề đấy Đó là các ông phải
á Đúng rồi tôi thiếu một cái đây nữa
kiếm một cái nữa đó là công nên chưa cây
thư mục có một vài nhóm tôi chấm là toàn
bộ cốt ở trong cùng một thư mục một thư
mục hiện một thư mục tận ba mươi mấy
file méo Nhìn cái đấy không thấy bị
choáng à
Anh cứ thấy nhìn ấn vào một cái thư mục
sau đó đi hiển thị ra đóng vai đang sợ
a cho tôi phải để mô mới ông xem
Ừ ông ấy chưa thư mục đúng à Tôi nhớ có
một ông gì chưa trong sợ cực cho anh xem
thử
anh ở bên admin 1 phát nữa thì bị ra hết
tất cả
10 cái này vẫn còn chưa cho mày vậy
Thì đại khái hiểu thì tôi không ạ
e-mail ngột ra ngọt là đúng mà vì hôm
nay là tôi đánh giá tất cả nhóm tất cả
nhóm nên ngột chứ không vào là các nhóm
mà còn đã nghĩ là chắc chắc Thầy trừ
mình ra chắc Thầy không nói nó mình đâu
Tôi không rút kinh nghiệm thì thì là tệ
rồi ông ạ mấy ông sẽ thấy mấy ông sẽ
phải tự suy nghiệm hôm
em tự ti thì nên có
khi a không phải nên có mạ tự ti không
đúng về dùng mà
anh nói chung là tôi thường ai đó là
phải biết biết mình biết ta đấy
Anh biết mình yếu ở đâu mạnh điểm nào để
mà rút kinh nghiệm và phát triển cái
điểm mạnh lên thì đấy mấy con người kiểu
đấy Mở con người mạnh
em có người mạnh là biết điểm yếu của
mình
khi con người có người yếu ở là kiểu
nghĩ rằng mình luôn đúng mình luôn kiểu
mình luôn mạnh say I
Ừ ok Bây giờ mình sẽ thử lớp qua giao
diện của từng nhóm mình không xem nhé
đầu tiên thì tôi có ở đây tôi sẽ đợi tí
thôi xem qua về cái danh sách nhóm đã
cho mình xem nhé
gì đáng quá đáng giá qua trước phải giao
diện đi nếu bạn trước trước khi nói về
cốt là qua giao diện thì ông xem nào mày
cái tôi thấy có phải đặt có phải đã yêu
cầu tôi chưa Đọc cốt kỹ được tới đưa
ngay chỉ xem một phạm một vài file
thường là file xử lý để mà xem qua là
các bạn cốt trông có vẻ như thế nào chứ
chứ tôi không phải đánh giá được từng
từng dòng của từng vay cho tôi chết mất
ngoại đây à
à à
để từ từ xem phim khách hàng như tôi
công nhận ở không biết ông ấy Ông có ôm
thư viện gì không thấy mấy ông cút tô
bảo mấy ông biết xe thuần mà mày ông tốt
cho mèo hàng tháng đấy không biết chắc
chắn là mấy ông có thể call CS từ một
cái thư viện nào đó về đúng không Nhìn
chồng rất hoành tráng Cái này ra là
không biết được sản phẩm thật hay không
Trả đây để mua rồi à
khi
khách hàng không ạ Min gì đấy à
a
poor viên à
Ừ bác quản lý tiệm cận ngay sợ rồi còn
lý để cho nhân viên nghỉ à
cô gái quản lý sản phẩm này là hiển thị
ra như thế này chọn về tương đối rồi
Ừ thế thiệp ạ
à Nhìn giống mẹ hấp dẫn nhưng mà tôi
từng nói chở ra cái này là không chắc
khả thi cho lắm cái bàn Online vì nó cần
thêm mà thời hạn có thiếu thứ Chứ ông
đang mưa sản phẩm nhé
anh cái mã thì loại là không hợp lý đấy
nó nên là tên thể loại nó bị hơn này mà
Mấy ông Thực ra nếu về sau để cho trải
nghiệm người dùng nhìn trong bài tốt hơn
thì ca mấy ông lên cho hiển thị chọn cái
thể loại ở trên này cứ tơ thể loại hiển
thị đã luôn đấy Tìm kiếm rồi không biết
tìm kiếm gì à Chắc theo tên à
Anh ở quên sắp đi lấy nhóm 1
Ở nhóm 2 này nhằm mua thì xem quá cố
tình sẽ là à
mã
sản phẩm đấy à
ý thức An ah
a Cho tôi hỏi các bạn nên tạo file Index
thay vì là tên là quản lý sản phẩm hay
là gì đó lấy cái thứ nhất thứ hai là tên
tên thư mục có rồi tên file không cần
nhất bạn
sẽ gọi shipper à
anh alo tên tên tên tên thư mục không
không nên tên file không nên nhắc lại
tên thư mục hạn chế điều đấy
bài hát Cập nhật lại à quên tôi chưa cập
nhật đây bơ tôi thử cập nhật hết một lần
nhé này tôi ấn cần thêm tệ cập nhật hết
Ê mày không thay đổi như thế
à Hôm nay ngày chập nữa mà không thay
đổi đúng không
anh nghe đấy tôi bảo mấy ông này em phải
thay đổi trước thì cũng phải đến bếp
like mới phút lên không ạ lỗi cốt gì đó
thì như nào sửa trong lúc này chị mà
không ạ ạ
ở lại nhà chung là bây giờ kéo hết Cốt
về này sau đó tôi lại phải chạy cái file
được inbox lại cốt này mệt thế Tôi không
biết được có lỗi gì ở không nữa không ạ
Alo
content này
có phải inbox
À mà hôm trước là tôi có để inbox
111 nhóm nghỉ xả đấy ạ
anh không chứa tôi mới sợ lại Cốc này
nữa rồi tối ưu hơn nữa kiểu là không cần
nhập tên thư mục mà lấy cột lấy thư mục
hiện tại luôn là ngày có muốn cụ thể một
nhóm 2 loại trừ nhóm nào không này đấy
có hiển thị ra
lỗi không
em hẹn bỏ qua này cho tôi sẽ dốc hết đi
inbox lại nè
khi chúng tôi sửa lại code khá nhiều À
thì ra không cần chia sẻ buổi cái đấy
vào trong livestream ra sợ em nhìn cái
thứ gì
xin lỗi nhóm 19 bật lỗi ạ nhầm 32
xin lỗi ok
à à
Ừ Ok bây giờ Nhóm 19 Tôi nhớ không lầm
mà hôm trước tôi sửa được rồi
à à
I find five nhóm 19 là tờ bay luôn à
Em nói cái vụ này nè
Âm Nhạc
I can not at all
I won Ki
sẽ giúp
castelli bucatarie ID
a loạn lùn không
Ừ cái nỗi nói đây Ừ ừ không biết nối này
được không Nhưng có phải đang báo lỗi
này
ừ
nóng này thử cái export Thôi bây giờ khá
là lạ khác với những nhóm khác thiếu cả
report thông tin nữa
à à
Ừ ok nhóm mày cứ sửa nhóm mày trước và
chạy thử Mỗi nhóm này nhá chạy lần lượt
từng nhóm này đầu tiên tôi đã ký kết cái
Tab nữa lên này nhóm 19 lỗi Đúng không
sửa lại chạy Mỗi nhóm 19 đây ạ
xin lỗi
à à
à à Như lỗi liên quan cái này on updates
này hôm trước là nhờ tôi nói rồi on ghệ
on up đấy cho thử như bị lỗi
đồ chó đồ được
nhóm mới có thể xóa cái ra ngoài đi
khi con update xét hay tự tử như ép máy
kéo nhưng không hỗ trợ tiếp theo nhóm 20
ở lại cũng ngon update anh à Mày giống
nhau
ở nhóm này không có file mà đúng không
đây không mà đúng
chị xem nhé hai nhóm mà còn nhiều file
cơ đúng không nhỉ
em ở đâu đó đã đỡ tí nha
khi cài đặt vị tao đi kết cái
ở cốt của tôi đang lấy lại cái Euro từ
cũ rồi để xem nhé á
Anh check Euro bằng không này nếu không
có file
ở
đây lại các em đúng ạ
em ở đó
anh
có thể bị cho nó luôn chấm Không nó bị
ghi đè lên kéo ngay xảy ra nhóm này
không có nhóm mày không import được
nhưng lấy cốt cũ bỏ qua này à
a32
332 lỗi gì
Ừ cái này sắp xếp cây thư mục của đây
lại theo nó biến hình chuỗi thành ra là
kiểu chữ cái đâu Cái số ba nói ở trên
à
à đôi số 3 ở dưới này vì kiểu này số 3
như này lại cùng cung cấp với 30 32 gì
đó
ở sân bay Plus
ừ ừ
nó báo lỗi ngày dòng này
à à
phụ trách nhiệm xa nó báo lỗi ngay tại
sao mày luôn
ờ ờ
à à
Ừ hình như nhóm mã 32 hôm trước tôi chạy
cũng bị lỗi thôi Lúc Họ sửa lại rồi vậy
a
star trong section
à à
Ê mày nhóm khác thì lại phát thành công
ở xem thử nhé ba tư chắc
ca nhạc ngã
ba tư có
file đồ án
à à
dịch vụ án một chân vt-5002i
khi tôi thấy bình thường mà Tại sao phải
cái này bị lỗi nhỉ cái ảo diệu cái gì
a wifi này khác gì nhau đâu
có điều export là có nhiều rửa mặt thể
thao đầy báo lỗi ngay tại cái giọng lần
đầu tiên nghỉ
ngày dòng đầu tiên vào lỗ luôn
khi nó báo lỗi à
cú pháp
à à
Ừ
đúng thế khác nhau
ở
đảo rượu vãi
à à
xe
ô tô cũ cấp có gì thủ công này sẽ thẳng
bên A
Ừ cái này nha
A và tiền tôi cà rốt mà đi à không cần
a32 nó không ạ ạ
aa33 ông trước thì nhớ cũng rất nhiều
à Hôm trước thằng ở lại có thành công
rồi không đi là sao tự nhiên đều bị lỗi
à à
Anh
ấy có được mà cũng có sai thì được
anh không hiểu Tôi không hiểu à
à à Ừ
nó bảo nó ngay từ dòng này sai này Ô thế
hạnh cho mày không chạy được chú thích
này nhưng tôi nhớ Tôi có cái câu là bọ
chú thích rồi lại một chú thích rồi này
bỏ đi
trẻ sơ sinh
ý tưởng mày sắp Châu Trinh đã kiểm tra
nếu mà
có tồn tại cái này thì bỏ đi được thì
chắc đi
à à
em gửi báo lại thằng 32 nha chạy
ở đó chưa đội
xe tải đời I
à à
Ừ cái sắp sờ chim kia Hình như là cái
dòng đầu tiên like này đang có vấn đề
thế thì tôi thử đài cái like đã
nữa biến thành giờ đi bốc thông cảm đãi
ở Thái Bình thường mà
Ừ
cái à
A
Pink pro cái sport
bạn đã like xong rồi không Nó ngoại lấy
hai đấy Hàng Da
Ông Táo Phải chi imports vừa rồi là
chuyện gì nhỉ
Em sắp string the worst suy nghĩa cắt
chuỗi I
ừ ừ
à à
em không cắt chuỗi nó ra kí tự đặc biệt
Âm Nhạc
Ừ thì là nó không nó không bằng bằng
được với đấy giống này nhưng thôi bỏ
quay Tôi dùng Trinh sport thì có vẻ ổn
hơn và kiểm tra là dòng đấy có
dòng đấy có chú thích à
anh không hiểu cứ kệ không sao
sau khi export ra thì gần như là dòng
nào có có cái này chết hẳn rằng bé chú
thích rồi chắc không sao đâu ok
ở thời đại khá đi ỉa tiếp nha Xem 52
Ừ cái điều đấy điều
anh Linh chưa Linh Mình nhớ không lầm là
hình như bạn đấy bị điều hướng á
anh
nói gì nhỉ
các bạn ạ Dùng à không phải đường dẫn
trực tiếp nhé bạn đấy dùng không không
dùng
ở Bạc Linh không phải cậu chấm chấm như
này vòng ra bạn ấy Linh kiểu như này
thôi khiến cho kiểu nó ghi đè lên cái
ghi đè lên nếu mình đang ở trong cái sắp
sự à
A gọi sắp pass tất cả năm chỉ kiểu Đường
Dẫn con thì bị thế còn nếu mà bạn ấy
chạy hỏi trên máy các bạn đấy thì không
không bị cái việc là bấm nào
Ừ nó bị kiểu xóa cái số 2 y bởi vì a đây
Đây là cái đông domaine bạn ấy mà đúng
không ạ ạ thế bạn đấy chị em giản là
thay nó bằng cả cụ mày nữa là xong không
ạ thay toàn bộ những cái sau về domaine
thành cái đường dẫn của bạn đấy lại ghi
kiểu Đường Dẫn anh cảm ngay ăn minh như
này đấy Sao ABC nha Nhưng mà như mình
dậy thì nên lại chậm sục ra như này đấy
thì để mà không không bị cái tình trạng
Kiểu như mình đang bị dính vào khi bấm
vào như thế này thì xóa mất kỹ sư về số
2 mình đi ông ạ là mình chứ chứ không
Bạn ấy kiểm tra trên máy bạn đấy thì vẫn
ổn thôi
ở lại như này đỡ buồn thôi
ai ngờ nóng này chưa Xbox cài Á đây bê
ra
dữ liệu ra Nên chưa xem được cái gì cả
gà trống trơn
Ê mày các bạn nên mới có dữ liệu ra thì
mình mình này già nó không ạ Không thì
mình thêm một sản phẩm cũng được
Ừ
Anh à Hôm nay tôi sẽ cho mày không xem
ảnh gì
phụ nữ sinh trung học ở thực
hiện từ hạn chế trên trên trang các bạn
có nữa anh ở Việt nhé các bạn anh thống
nhất toàn bộ tiếng Anh trong tiếng Việt
cũng hơn à
ở nhà sản xuất danh mục không có danh
mục có này nó sẽ không có
thêm nữa không thêm được bỏ qua vậy
đi tiếp nhỉ À đúng rồi còn bên khách
hàng thì sao
ở đó
ở FPTShop
Ừ rồi chồng về tương đối chứ không ạ
Ừ kệ tôi tôi dùng máy tôi thường ai rung
lên để màn hình to mà kéo nó bị vỡ không
xa tổ chưa cần bé ông làm kẹo before
ship là gì cả
a83 này à
chính xác diễn lỗi lỗi này là lỗi code
của mấy ông ấy nhá Không phải lỗi do mày
tôi đâu
anh đúng không nằm bơ pho mát rồi Do
ngồi
ở vị trí địa chỉ nghĩ thật nha
Sơn Hạnh à
ê kê
hả Mà hình như không cho đăng nhập rồi
còn lý do Hà Nội ạ amin có lấy rõ ta
được
a Vietnamese sao ạ
Ừ cái này rồi không biết lừa thật đã như
lừa đấy là lượt
Ê
mấy ông thầy có 4 sản phẩm mà bên kia 10
giờ rồi mà
chậm tương đối rồi chưa kiểu này thật là
Ừ cũng được tùy thì người sẽ thích kiểu
này tôi thích em ạ thường đó boss thì
nên hiển thị trong bạn hơn bởi vì ạ
người ta kiểu Slow kéo xuống tôi từng
nói về trải nghiệm Uy người dùng rồi
người ta khi mà sẽ muốn xem lướt khác
phải xem kiểu để mà xem cụ thể một cái
dòng sản phẩm thì mày xem cụ thể Còn nếu
muốn xem nước thì người ta thường ai trỏ
chuột ở bên phải này để mà ấn sửa gì đó
còn xóa Thì đó nhanh chứ không phải kiểu
kiểu đọc từ trái sang phải kéo xuống đọc
từ trái sang phải trải nghiệm mới không
tốt
thì nên là các bạn nên thay cái này bằng
dạng thay bồ sẽ hợp lý hơn
Ừ hi vọng vào nhóm anh nghe
ở nhóm 4 thì như không có để tôi xem lại
chính sách nhóm đó tự động 5 Trang Khiếu
ạ Không biết thiếu gì đấy mình chống lại
thiếu mịn à
xe khách hàng rồi
em chẳng nhớ nhắm lại thiếu gì nữa
Em có nhóm bỏ rồi không nhớ rồi tôi phải
chỉ chọn nó lại có thư
nhóm mày đúng rồi Tôi nhớ bên này khá ôn
nhớ đến ăn mì mì Như tinh thiếu và bỏ
qua đi
356 à Làm sao cũng thiếu
Ừ ở đâu vậy xem nhé Để xem nhé
Ừ hình như mới nổi vậy thôi Chưa thấy
giao diện này bao giờ
chưa thấy các bạn làm ra diện hoành
tráng đẹp phết tốn khá nhiều thời gian
mà lấy
Ừ
ông ấy không phanh đấy luôn ạ ạ
à à
có gì
anh thấy bảo phải nào bây giờ Superman
ở đâu rồi tra nhóm mày chưa cập nhật bên
à could nỗi thơ bỏ qua lỗi bỏ qua nắm
tay
Ừ
ông nhìn cái biết ngay bạn làm cái này
là nam hay là nữ
Em à từ ra tôi nói thế là mấy ông sẽ đi
ngay nhưng mà ạ Thế là mấy ông hiểu mà
không ạ đi
I
am in thử đi như cái này chưa Bấm được
anh mất Kpop Hồi trước rồi cái to hơn
trước hay hay mà lại xài rồi
à à
ô ồ chọn chức năng chống chịu với
vì thế kiểu này lúc đầu hai thôi về sau
sẽ khó chịu người dùng muốn vào xem được
xem luôn Nhưng thôi không sao cũng được
cũng cũng là một cái gì a22
vào phải đăng nhập nhé Chắc làm các bạn
chưa kiểm tra vụ đăng nhập ở trong một
mẹ phép riêng kế bên này không bấm được
mấy cái bên này chắc quên cho say đi
không bấm được bên này mày bấn được hai
nút đăng xuất này bối rối quá
Thế hả Bây giờ ông ấy ấp đấy đó thôi bỏ
qua
Anh đợi ở tính
nếu rút kinh nghiệm nhé Thì nói chung là
tôi bảo tôi có thông báo ấy là đét like
trước khi trước trước khi livestream à
[âm nhạc]
Ê con chó lại tao động vậy
Ừ đúng rồi đúng giờ này
300 đánh nó có phải ngày nào tụi mày
đúng là ngày nào thì anh nói thật nhưng
mà có phải cái gì đó đánh nó rồi
ngày nào rồi đánh nó bởi vì nó bị em bị
sổ láo ý
trưa nay nó vừa sửa thôi nhưng mà tôi
kiểu từ trong nhà tắm đi ra cay lẫn
chú chó sủa chủ được thể thế không muốn
nó xuống mày sợ bình thường dù gặp phải
thưởng kia tôi đánh nó nó bắt đầu bị dìm
xuống nhưng ở nó gọi đòn à
Ừ tôi từng nuôi mèo ấy chứ con mèo hình
nhưng mà chán cho tôi nó bỏ đi à Buồn
mãi à
Ừ ok diện Bên anh nhìn lại thấy nó diện
người nhiều tiền rồi chúng mày rất đẹp ạ
à à
em có công cụ để đo Pixel á Có đấy Ờ nó
rule các bạn ruler là thức kẻ thôi xét
extension này
nó có đo cụ thể cận kỹ vết nhân này
anh nói đĩa Pixel đẹp phết I
em không khóc vì như cái này không đúng
như vậy Nói cho các bạn tra rule là được
Google assistant được
à à
Tai nghe xịn mãi
Ok đi theo onme này
thống kê thống kê Điều đấy nếu mà về sau
tôi sẽ dậy Có thể tôi sẽ dậy mày ông thì
nhớ thống kê thứ hai và làm biểu đồ này
các sự có dậy hết những cái gì ông bảo
ông hỏi mà tôi làm được hòa Tôi chưa làm
được thì cũng sẽ người mò để hướng dẫn
và mấy ông ạ
à à
đi tìm về sau thực ra ông này có thống
kê này khá là ổn so với cái bạn trước
đấy bạn trước thống kê nó khá là mù mờ
bởi vì một trang web bán hàng ấy thì là
phải rất cần những cái thống kê kiểu như
này đó là thứ không cần tất cả đơn hàng
mà đang xử lý như nào đang giao như là
Vân Vân thậm chí trong ngày hôm nay nữa
nếu mà Peter được trong ngày hôm nay vẫn
và Vần nữa thì sẽ rất ổn ở chùa các bạn
là làm đồ ăn một cái ra mình cũng chưa
Mình cũng chưa đòi hỏi các bạn về việc
là các bạn phải hiểu rõ bài toán vân vì
về cơ bản các bạn có biết rõ bên bán
hàng người ta cần gì đâu nhưng
nhưng mà ở vì sau mình sẽ phải đề cập
các bạn về cái vụ là các bạn sẽ phải
hiểu rõ là người dùng cần gì để làm
những cái mình mang phù hợp với người
dùng đó Ngoại ạ anh không chỉ là mỗi
xanh thêm sửa xóa không không nữa Hồi
đấy các bạn phải nắm rõ rồi các bạn sẽ
phải làm những cái tính năng từ sự người
dùng gắn những loại
Ừ cái này được ông ấy thì copy về đâu mà
toàn bộ HT mừng rồi đấy Có gì đâu
chỉ có mỗi đoạn này CS bị lệch tông ấy
cho buồn cười ghê tiếp
nhóm 11 tháng 11 hình như là
những của bạn như vậy mới nhìn bạn không
biết được có cái gì cho mấy ông không
lỗi
mà chắc mới sữa lại cái á
Anh tên database in lỗi rồi
I am in connect
I am in Connect này 11A
ở
shopee à
ở showbiz
Ừ ok
ở
nhà ông cứ tốn hơn nhiều thời gian ở
giao diện chứ
ừ ừ
ơi
Quang Anh inbox nhiều phết Cái gì Thật
hay đùa đấy Olympus tại nhà này sản phẩm
nữa chạy tung nữa
nếu như có mùa hè sản phẩm ở đây lỗi
Không phải Xóa bớt điều nhưng mà inbox
như Tết I
ở nhóm kia rồi nhắc đến shopee không Mày
không nghe máy ảnh đúng không tự mẹ mày
đấy
a12 này
tôi đang thừa chấm tôi chấm xong hết rồi
nếu mày rồi đang chỉ cho các bạn xem qua
giao diện còn bổng sau sẽ chấm cách tử
tế các bạn xem là mình sẽ mở hàng file
cốt lên để đánh giá xem là một file code
đấy nên sửa những cái gì để tất cả nhóm
cùng chút kinh nghiệm đầy ngoạn
ở ngoài lập trình viên phải chạy tôn
chính tôi dậy mấy ông điều đấy mà chính
tôi Làm lập trình viên vì những cái điều
đấy ông ạ Ừ ông ấy như nhà làm cái cấu
trúc như cậu làm ở VC rồi Tùng bảo không
làm nên mới xe nữa làm rồi
nó không mà đúng lúc này mpc mà
Ẩm Thực ra tôi chẳng nhớ phải chạy cái
này như thế nào cơ quân sự mới rồi ở nhà
phải chạy cái á
Anh thường là phải vào thư mục public
rồi được rồi Mày hiểu bị sao ấy là xe
máy
cả hai ông này dùng T8 nghỉ thôi Dùng pp
7 nhé
Ừ tí rồi hỏi lại ông này vụ chạy cả ngay
nhé ông đấy hình đã ngon ở đây vậy
anh phải chạy cái lạnh thì nữa nó ông
Dũng ơi ông Bùi Dũng
em đọc đi mi nào
à à
thế này có bao giờ install điện cày cắt
bắt kịp Ừ đúng rồi xong rồi
service như thế này thì nó mới chạy lên
này à
Khi
tôi buồn không ạ ạ
khi đàn ông muốn tôi chạy đúng không
Lê Minh tomino rồi
à à
bộ
combo other của mình có mấy nhỉ à
bây giờ mình có mà Đợi tí nhé
[Vỗ tay]
Đúng rồi tôi cài rồi mà chạy Có bao giờ
em ạ
thủ thuật cài ở trong bị chung mục khác
rồi
à à à à
à à
ừ ừ
à
Xong rồi tôi không thấy cái file có mozo
reason ở đây mà đông
anh ở đây có mà
à Anh nhầm nhầm nào tôi sang nhóm 11
nhóm 12 nhóm 12 chế độ sửa lỗi tội lỗi
tôi
chỗ nào nào
à à
hai tay compose inter vẫn thế nhé
anh nói với inter đã không được rồi ạ ạ
ô kê
à à
để chứng tỏ ngoài cài hơn 1 đầm lắp gì
rồi là biết ngay
em ngồi cày nước à
Ừ nó hay cài túi áo rồi
anh khác
đi tìm món đồ này là không Tâm Bên Nồi
Tôi thường anh dùng nó là Commander cái
này cơ
Ừ tao không dùng cái tôi ít khi dùng cái
kiếm không dùng cái à for you nữa đâu
Ừ cái này có sẵn của là ngon dùm
Ê mấy ông như thế này tôi bảo Giờ đoán
một gam màu cũng không nên áp dụng nhiều
về cử như này bởi nó cơ bản đã cả mày
mày ông nó dụng như thế này mình gửi ông
cùng nhóm của ông mà không phải không
Không giỏi không không hiểu được mà
không biết chạy như thế nào đã
anh đã tự ý tôi này tôi đang phải ngồi
mò chạy này Buồn vãi ghê thế
Ừ thôi kệ không sao
là người giỏi tôi sẽ chấm cách người
giỏi như nhau rồi
U22 này
106 này nên
anh alo hút à đâu có khó chứ đừng có hót
này
nên là mười 12 này nè
I was your name Blue này khẩu trống này
cái để phải con fix I
Ừ địt nhau chạy mic nữa đậu xanh
à à
ở lỗ giống ơi
ở đây cho tôi ghét gì hết mấy lần lỗi cả
nhà vợ chồng biết mọi chứ
Ừ thôi Cái này tính sau nha Ngồi ngồi
sửa ông ấy hết sư thời ra mắt
để xem cốt thử xem
I Connect DB này Mr wah này còn làm vài
đứa rồi ok Ao này
trò chơi gì mấy chị có tạo này hiển thị
ra lưu lại này
Ừ chị ra này ông em mới làm làm một mình
hơi ít vậy hôm Tết
anh chưa có gì chưa có gì ý
anh nhìn chồng ngoại hoành tráng cho tốn
hết thời gian làm mấy cái kia rồi
bộ phim sex đây là m với xe Tôi đã bảo
mày không không làm mới với xe mấy ông
làm mới xe theo kiểu Phương Quốc mà nói
nhưng mọi mời xe bình thường
đăng nhập này à
cho người dùng hiển thị ra
còn làm nhiệt độ hướng đối tượng rồi Đấy
ấn tượng mà nó nghỉ Hôm nay hồi tưởng
chị sẽ có mua đồ đâu không à
e2s kiểu nói đối tượng rồi đúng không ạ
cho phép kiểu rồi
đại khái như thế thì ra bạn này làm như
thế xong hết thời bị kiểu
tối Nhờ là làm này quá
Nếu mà đương nhiên về sau làm thương
buốt phải làm đầy đủ tiền ăn thêm sửa
xóa nhé Thế đúng
như tôi tôi bảo rồi đoán một các bạn
chưa cần làm những cái đấy
a13
à à
gì
Kệ ông làm cùng ông ấy rỗi cũng bỏ rồi
ông Tôi buồn mấy ông lắm á
anh hả
Ừ ông anh nên sửa lại cái ý Ừ cái mật
khẩu
ô mai
a cosmetics
hình yêu nhóm mày tặng ở hai sao con ếch
này về sửa tận hai nơi buồn
ông ấy còn đặt mật khẩu đã bây nữa
logo hot người đang ngồi khẩu chứ
Ừ cái này là
lỗi cái này lỗi khi vẩn đấy nhé
Không thể sau bị lỗi vậy đó
ở khu đất mà
về saxophone Ford vẫn đúng rồi
A2 ở nhóm 13 không có xe tải
à à
à À đấy đúng lỗi chị Vân thật cô đa của
mình thì có chữ S đấy
có phản có chữ S có là không trên giờ
tôi từng dậy mấy ông mà thống nhất là là
thứ nhất là phải thống nhất thế ai là
bạn thì nên có chữ S được ạ tên cột thì
không nên có chữ S Thế bạn xuống nhiều
cho em cái đấy là đó cái để về sau tôi
dậy các bạn về bên lao leo ấy có những
tiêu chuẩn Devil nên lên đây thì nói thế
nghe Tôi đang dạy các bạn theo từng thế
đấy nếu để tiếng Anh của tiếng Việt thì
nhưng không tơ mét thì cả rồi đấy lỗi
Văn nhá ông ấy ông ấy chạy đoạn này đây
chưa sợ mấy giờ rồi
em xấu hổ quá trời gửi nha à
hai
lưỡi ảnh khó chịu thì ra lỗi chị vẫn
kiểu kia là sao mày không hiển thị ra là
mình không biết lỗi anh chị gửi ảnh hiển
thị LCD mà chị nhé Ok Thế mày ăn đi nhé
à
khi đăng nhập tôi toàn phải hack Hùng và
mấy ông nhé
Ừ nếu không có thể giống như nhóm bậy
tạm tắt cái không đăng nhập được không
sao đâu ạ
cái này đầy đủ tính năng thêm mới xóa và
Cõi sport 37 thế hộp rồi chọn cái tìm
kiếm này không biết tìm kiếm được không
không không em tôi không được tìm kiếm
niềm vui thôi anh như chưa có chưa có
phương tranh các bạn nên khó nên có giận
mấy cái vụ đấy
thế nào nhỉ
i10 14
à à
anh
em sẽ chẳng rất mạnh mẽ
Vợ
chồng ảo diệu ở khoản này phết
Ê mấy ông Mạnh nghĩ là mấy cái này về
sau tôi báo lỗi cũng mệt đấy ạ
Ừ tôi cứ kiểm tra bị an ninh trước đi
anh
Tại ông anh tổng hết mọi thứ có 1 file
đó một thư mục mày nóng lạnh tự nhiên là
có cô Đắc rồi gạch ngang là các thứ thứ
cũng được nhưng mà không không nên kéo
ngay à
anh có nhìn qua lại thôi xem thử nhé
ở ngoài này hình như là tôi đăng nhập
vào không được cả nhóm này nhóm mà tôi
đăng nhập vào không được vì sản phẩm
không có gì vậy mà còn chưa có sót lại
đi dp chưa
anh ở đây có có có à Ông này làm kiểu
mật khẩu của mã hóa Ông này ông khác
cũng khác đó là mật khẩu cả mã hóa sau
đó đi tôi phải bảo sữa cốt rồi mà khách
đưa vào cũng mệt À
mà thôi có khi ở Bỏ qua đi tôi ra và bên
cô đắp ở giờ tạm tắt cài á á
em ăn đi này
ô tô Đắc rồi
em có tắt cái vụ
cách kiểm tra đăng nhập rồi
à à
khi mở nhập nghị vào thì vẫn ế
Sau đó nhập viện 3 à
ở cây 5 pro
À mà thôi không cần đăng nhập được tính
sao đi vào thẳng đây rồi tắt cái check
zalo được mà à
à à
ô tô đặc đi
mình cầm cố trong tay mà đúng ạ
xin lỗi tùm lum này
à à
thế
là ok Gọi bố mày làm thí sinh nếu cậu là
để mà trách ai đem đề bà đúng rồi ông ơi
ông ạ Thấy chưa Không Thật ra không
không mày ông không nên làm Bởi vì Thật
ra ông này làm tống hết vào trong một
thư mục này ra là ông đấy lưu lại là
mình đang ở trang nào đưa vào trong thí
sinh đi ha cốt ở trong sân thì có thể
lên không tốt nếu là các bạn một lần lấy
theo tên rồi file cũng được hoặc à tên
của thư mục thì hơn các bạn nhét cái này
vào trong thư mục thì hơn
chị Hà đi tài khoản mật khẩu cho thầy ra
thôi Tại sao chúng ta phải làm thế khi
chúng đang hệ vào được luôn đúng ạ
à à
ừ ừ
ở quảng cáo tại mà do tại bác sĩ sẽ đi
không không không nên nhưng mà ý là tạm
tắt cái file đi này phải pha này thật ra
ông ông thích thì ông vào phải này không
ạ
Ừ chắc đâu rồi
Ừ ông bỏ cái dòng này đi không ạ Bỏ dòng
này đi được bao nhiêu vào mọi phanh sẽ
thế thôi mà Bình thường mà không ạ
cô
dâu mấy cái trang của ông có ra ngoài
mạng xã hội đâu Đúng nói đi avatar đấy
bảy màu à ok
Ê mấy ông cũng phải sửa lại mấy cái hiển
thị này Chị sao cho người dùng dễ hiểu
dễ rung không ạ
từ khóa tìm kiếm hay đi ỉa cũng được tìm
thấy tên có thể trùng tìm cái đi học nêm
hoặc có phone được này không ạ thì cái
thông tin các thứ thứ này cho dễ hình
dung con tí
Ừ ok 54 ổn ổn rồi đúng không được 15 này
15 khiếu à Không nhớ thiếu gì
à à
are
you search in the face of
ở hà nhóm 15 như chưa có gì vậy
xem lại nha à
a cho ngắm 15 chưa có gì cả bỏ qua đi Nó
16 thiếu không phải Nhóm thiếu mài nhọn
có vào nhóm được tạo sau nữa nhận thức
thửa ở cũng không biết nào
Anh nói chơi Dino
Anh
ngồi chơi gì nó ok
a57 I
khi nấu nên mong nhóm mạo hoành tráng
đúng không Không hoành tráng đâu ạ
I am in được nào ạ
a
cho báo thức cưới nóng mày
bây giờ đang đi cỡ
ừ ừ
Ừ
ok rồi
a57 tổ đội thiếu đánh giá ổn Ok qua giao
diện hội Vĩ trải nghiệm hội nghị sao đấy
thì sửa sau thấy sửa được sữa nhanh
U18 hội
ở ngã diện người dùng
Ừ cái này không biết ở Có phải bạn nữ
làm không trả nhờ đó
Anh là con trai nạn có sao đâu đúng
không
ở nhà mà cũng tìm hiểu về giao diện ạ
Từ ngày ông ấy không có ăn bim không ai
tên file hướng lên viết hoa nhé
ông kể
ở chỗ chị mà đúng ạ chị
xin lỗi cái lỗi kết nối 58a
đã sửa mày nghỉ à
vì vậy ông ấy đây này có một nhóm nhiều
sữa trong cả
đã kết nối ngay ở trong file rồi phát
sáng admin này step mà đi chơi rồi
đã kết nối lại nhóm này không chen em
những file khác cách sửa thủ công từng
cái chuyện anh không tốt
những kiểu ngay à
khi
con trai không sao không nhận
Ý tôi nói về cái mắt thẩm mĩ thoát thẩm
mỹ có vẻ hơn ý nghĩa hơn tôi à
bài hát tôi yêu cầu miếng là mùa Mẹ đâu
mày ông màu mè Tôi chấm điểm chỉ được
tối đa là được cộng thêm 1 điểm thôi
khi cây bụi đầu mấy ông mẹ tự thưởng
nhau kiểu giao diện màu mè này ông này
cũng bắt chước tôi có Sơn Lai Châu rồi
hay
web này
a web mân có cái gì đó Nami mà không
biết được cho à
anh không không phải ăn mi nữa Nói gì
nhỉ
cho phép này access không
a a bên này mới lạ chưa chưa làm đến
amin à đúng không ạ a59
em gửi xem
à à
À mà thôi lộ hết Đứng lên Ừ mà tính sau
nhắn tin sau em
Ừ ừ
nhóm 20 thiếu nói cái gì nhỉ à
ở ngoài tách ở 2 nhóm
thế này như là biminne II
em à Cái này không phải thiếu mình nhờ
tôi đang yêu cầu nhóm này gộp lại nhóm
mày nó tách ra kiểu gì không Không dịch
được cho mình cần phải sửa lại việc rồi
lại có 2 thư mục này tôi chẳng viết thư
mục và thông mình nào
từ năm 21 này
xe khách hàng
khi sex
Ơ hay
Ừ ok
I am in ra à
Ừ anh nhớ mà lưu ý một điều là hôm Để mồ
tôi sẽ nghiêm túc tôi không có cất nhà
cười đùa thì ông nên làm mấy ông cũng
phải nghiêm túc thực sự đó là
anh không không có sản phẩm gì ở vớ vẩn
không có kiểu tiêu đề vớ vẩn nó chỗ vào
mọi thứ như doanh nghiệp như thật đấy
ông ạ Hôm nay tôi sẽ là các bạn đấy nhá
Ừ hôm đấy nữa tôi sẽ tăng rất căng Tôi
có thể đuổi nhóm không cho nhóm để bảo
vệ nữa phải đợi bảo vệ đồ sau có
anh gọi
cho nên mấy ông không không ạ Không hiểu
cần nhà hôm đấy được đâu ạ
ừ ừ
anh
yêu tôi chậm cái này
à à
Em không biết được không anh sao
em không được thì mình lại hack vọng là
phân
đâu Cái phom áo chân lại nhớ đến chính
nó đóng ạ Ơ sao
[âm nhạc]
lại đi tôi sự con chó Phạm
kìa mày ông có vẻ thích tôi bảo hành con
chó nhé ạ
anh em cảm nhận nó là chó phốc bé tí mồm
to thật
ờ ờ
anh đọc đợi rồi đi tập bơi trong Ai đi
sao
Ừ
thôi tôi hack mà xem hack được không
tin thì được nha
khi đăng nhập không thành công ở cho bà
bà đế cao thủ thôi
khi copy vào đỡ phải sẽ có được mật khẩu
Ừ ok
về menu menu Note II
cô đơn hàng tổng quan về và ở không nào
tổng quan luôn hiển thị menu Mino nóng
lạnh
Anh tên là hết mệt à trải nghiệm không
tốt lắm
cơ sở lại tên mấy cái file này
ở trong giao diện cũng được nghe có thêm
tí ra Swift nữa cả
CS để hiển thị trong moma không ạ rất mù
me I
Ừ mà mày để làm gì mà mẹ chị dành cho
giới trẻ thôi rồi chạy biết mu me con
người mà đi làm muộn gì đó rất là kiểu
ổn rồi
anh chả nhớ nhóm 22 ở như thế nào nữa
đúng hay tôi để đạt à
D3 từ nhà nội à
e3d v6
anh tính ở tôi không được đặt ở với sát
à À cái như vào đăng nhập tôi
anh alo mặc định vào đăng nhập
anh em
khi đăng ký
Ừ thôi mới đổi sang xài đấy Lại ngắm 12A
I am in
à À không Hôm nay đi xem Cốt
Ừ thì nhớ bảo chưa làm được diện
ở lại bãi có cốt các thử rồi
em
sửa lại giao diện nhé tôi chấm này Sao
lại bên anh chưa đạt đi ừ
Ừ ok nhóm 23 nhé bây giờ giao diện tôi
bảo làm từ hôm từ tuần đầu mà ngoại tao
giao diện cứ rồi bạn đấy
nó diện có Rồi sẽ lắp vào thôi cần sửa
lại tí
Ở nhóm 2 3 chữa karaoke à
Em không biết đã sửa chưa Thế là có vài
bạn thiếu sao mà cậu ấy lại lỗi câu truy
vấn này chịu anh ạ Không sai mấy câu
thôi vừa vào trang xay chung kiểu hôm
bảo vệ không không được Kiểu như thế đâu
nhá
có gì anh không tìm thấy file đây là
không tìm thấy pháo anh nhé chắc phải
không phải
thế giờ rồi nó không ghép cốt chưa chưa
ghét Xong lại lên rồi hả khi kéo Cốt về
thì mày không phải chạy lại thử lại chứ
ở đây lactum anh ạ
ở vùng đất
anh alo mùa đông
anh
phải sục Xuka à
Anh không biến xa Tiên Biến sạc có say
quá
ở nhóm Mày đúng là thiếu Đúng rồi 299
à à
bộ
sạc bạn kia vẫn bạn kia người mới hỏi
của ngôn ngữ
vì sao mình bị ngại trả lời mấy câu mình
trả lời rồi Ờ bạn nào trả lời hộ mình
trong nhiều nhớ lúc hiểu các bạn trả lời
hộ mình mấy cái bình luận mà mình đã
từng trả lời rồi phát
Cô nói đi nói lại mấy cái thì tôi nghĩ à
vừa bị cũng tốn thời gian các bạn thôi
ông ạ
I am in
em hả Hay hay thôi rồi bỏ qua bỏ qua à
Ừ
ông 22/3 minh đúng không
ừ ừ tôi tôi tôi nhớ Tôi nhớ là phải cái
kéo admin thì hình như vậy và được không
ạ
Ừ mẹ ngoại làm đăng nhập tốt hơn nữa
có ai trở lại hai anh nhá 23 vừa rồi sai
mấy cái lỗi gì cho tôi bỏ qua
ở lại bên đăng nhập khẩu hiệu này
nhóm 22 câu ký phép đảm bảo mật các thứ
như tôi không quan tâm tôi với tôi tôi
điền bữa Đúng là được
thôi sửa lại câu truy vấn của ông ấy
thôi
i
h u
đi khám hồi 22 này chưa chưa
ở đây chợ Expo đặt database những dữ
liệu làm gì có đấy tôi bảo tôi đăng nhập
có vào được đâu
Làm sao mà thể hack được vào khi mà khi
mà không có tài khoản đúng ngoại ý
Ừ ông đồ rồi à
chai Vậy đậu xanh
thế tôi bảo phải chấm cốt đấy có đăng
nhập được đâu
để chiều người
kho ở
I
spent tôi phải tắt cái vụ này đi rồi
kiểm tra ở bộ à
anh nói tôi nhiều lúc tắt chị kho là
dừng nữa
ờ ờ
A gọi đến cọ
ừ ừ
cho tao xem
à à
ừ ừ
anh
ở đây này tắt mày nữa tao cả này nữa
Ông kiểm tra kiểm tra thận hai lớp nữa
lại kiểm tra lớp ở ngoài cái thu ngoài
cái file kiểm tra được ra sẽ không tốt
không có thông tin gì cả nhà ô tô vẫn
chấm bạn Đạt với bạn ơi cấu tạo được hết
file tôi phải Đọc cốt bạn đấy
đậu xanh
chấm rửa hơi mệt thế Ông làm tôi thấy
Ê mấy ông mấy ông hiểu cảm giác ơi trả
bài Chưa ạ nó kiểu bị mệt đi
đầy đủ La nhưng mà đủ theo kiểu là phải
cho có với chấm áp lực với anh ạ
ý là không mình không dạy ở trường nào
nỡ rồi mình dậy mỗi trên này thôi à
Em có phải bạn lạ mới được đề xuất bình
kênh của mình à cha lớn nó đang
livestream gì nữa nói được tăng tăng
lượng tiếp cận tiếp cận người biết
em nhớ anh nếu mà mấy bạn mới mấy bạn
xem video của mình hiện tại cũng chẳng
hiểu mày đang nói gì mấy
hơi thế thì hơi buồn cho nó bạn hãy xem
cái video khác
ở nhà bạn kia nói nhanh lên chị nhàn
không béo
à à
anh không ai bán
nỗi nhớ xóa chặn
ở nhóm này để tôi cho đủ ok
ẩm thực Việt Nam miền Đông Á à à
à à
Ý tao hỏi để im bố là tách mạng ok
thì tại sao ở tuổi cho nhóm này đủ để
xem nhé
dự án đùa đục cốc thôi còn giao diện thì
hơi tệ
Ừ cái đấy cả thiện sau vì sao tính sau
ở vòng 32 thiếu giới thiệu gì xem nhé
Nhóm 32 cái nhóm của sữa cậu ạ em không
học anh queo đấy do export tự nhiên Oppo
vấn đề này Thế bây giờ cũng mấy inbox
được vào không biết là bây giờ mình chấm
rẽ trong nha Chồng mày đẹp phết nhỉ Xem
em ạ
xin lỗi cái nổi
nghe nói sửa lại đường bạn amin Connect
à
lời
bài hát mẹ
chồng cũng có vẻ ổn
có thêm này
từ ra các bạn không nên nhảy nhảy Sang
trang khác mà bay mất cái menu đồng
ngoại
ừ ừ
các
bạn bay mất menu mai mất mấy cái đấy cả
thể không tốt không ạ Các bạn phải sửa
lại được đấy
vợ
chồng có vẻ ổn rồi đấy thôi Tôi Chưa
test được mấy cái tính năng thực sự đâu
À thỉnh thoảng tuần sau tô mới chấm mấy
cái file xử lý nhé tạm xem qua có đầy đủ
đầy đủ các tính năng thôi chưa chấm được
được tính năng mà tôi cứ tạm đánh giá
đấy á cũng Tuần sau tôi sẽ kiểm tra kỹ
hơn mày cái đấy
à à
anh
nói thế để tôi ghi lại đi tôi cứ ghi lại
tội hay quên lắm tôi thì lại
cho nên này
có cấu trúc cây thư mục nhớ đừng như ông
kia gửi theo kiểu mới copy nhé ờ
mục tiêu chí chấm bây giờ mới này còn
đây là
giải thưởng vụ đi
không phải giải thưởng vợ chung cư gì
nhỉ
các giải phụ à
còn tin thị trấn sẽ là đầy đủ
tính năng
xem thêm sữa xóa
anh như là tôi từng nói cái vụ đấy rồi
nhỉ
Hình như là tôi từng nói qua có cái file
có cái file đấy à em
gửi đó các bạn có cái file lại yêu cầu
các bạn đồ án phải có những cái gì rồi
Có
ừ ừ
a file
à à
Anh
Đài phần mô tả đồng hồ sơ mô tả đây Yêu
cầu phải có những cái này có rồi có rồi
mà
Ừ bắt buộc phải còn những cái này mà
thêm thì có thể đâu
Ê công nghệ áp dụng của Bác
lý thuyết trình
Cho tôi coi những cái này
Cho mày thêm thì các bạn sẽ phải có cả
bay date nhé Lần sau tuần sau mình sẽ
kiểm tra các bạn phải ba Tết
Ừ thế giờ này đi không không cần không
cần
Ừ thế thì mình nốt ở đây nó ra cho sau
sẽ cần lặp lại đấy
ok 32 coi ổn rồi ba tư ừ
à à
ở trong cũng có vẻ ổn thôi
ừ ừ
Nghe có vẻ đúng rồi còn mấy khách hàng
nữa
à à
xe khách hàng một Đặt tên hơi lạ
khi album văn phòng phẩm cũng được cũng
được
ở nhóm này nó nghỉ rồi ok tại Khánh thì
vừa rồi chấm qua các bạn thấy là đều khá
Ôn
ờ ờ
đi khám hả ổn thôi Nhưng mà đấy là những
nhóm còn đang làm còn những nhóm khác
thì trước bên A không ạ
anh tí nha Thì mình vẫn đang thấy đến
bây giờ vẫn đang đi đúng đúng như kế
hoạch thì vọng các bạn vẫn tiếp tục làm
được và có thăng gì thì nên nhắn tin sớm
nhà như sớm không không nên kiểu đến
cuối tuần vừa rồi đấy mày ông mới bắt
đầu cập nhật cố tình có thứ
anh
nói chung á Tôi bé không thể loại được
cái nhòm Đúng rồi
loại mấy ông ấy thì ông cũng có quan
trọng đâu
Ừ nhưng mà nói chung là không bảo vệ tôi
vẫn sẽ ra gặp thôi Nói rồi anh sẽ gặp sẽ
thể hiện được cái áp lực
hi vọng các bạn đợi được đến hôm bảo vệ
thôi ông ạ
ở buổi hôm nay chắc là chị tưởng đội thế
thôi bị thật là tôi đã chấm qua những
nhóm này rồi còn tuần sau rồi chắc là
tôi sẽ không phải mất tầm 2 tiếng nữa
ngồi chém tất cả nhóm kiểm tra code các
thứ nữa Lúc Ê sẽ đánh giá cụ thể hơn tư
nhóm sau
anh em và tôi kiểm tra một vài phải ngẫu
nhiên thôi các bạn kiểu gì cũng phải cốt
một cái tử tế từ đầu đến cuối không ạ
đúng ạ Chứ tôi mà kiểm tra Bất Chợt Một
file nào đó mà Mấy ông không có bảo là
đen cả anh ơi kiểm tra khác đi không
không chuyện đời đó có kiểm tra cốt ở
kiểm tra lôgic Nga trong bài kiểm tra về
giao diện nữa không ạ
anh em các bạn Nói chung là bởi vì ở tôi
đang
tôi đang kẹo em nghiêm túc tôi sẽ kiểm
tra một cách tỉ mỉ không ạ ạ
ờ ờ
anh em chưa được duyệt tài liệu để làm
em à Ok có một vài nhóm được à tội chẳng
nhớ là đang tiến độ đến đâu nữa Cho tí
tôi xem lại mấy cái đấy
tớ xem cụ thể từng nhóm nó lại sau trước
bây giờ Xem tổng quát được cả không nhớ
nhắm vào nhóm mà nhiều nhau khỏe
Ừ thôi Cháu bữa hôm nay thế thôi có gì
những câu hỏi nào các bạn hỏi thì thì bộ
sau mình sẽ tổng hợp và trả lời sau nhé
chả bạn nhé Đúng rồi chúc mừng năm mới
nhé
Thì gọi mà là tôi nhắc về cái chút nữa
tâm tâm sự cuối bộ Hà Nội nốt nốt nốt đó
là nói với cái trúc thì à
anh không biết có bạn quan điểm về cái
trúc và như thế nào nhưng nhưng
nói nói chào cho mấy mấy mấy ông kia
Tháp mất rồi thôi ông sao
không biết nữa Ông có điểm trúc như thế
nào nhưng mà với tôi quan điểm chút đấy
Nó là kiểu
sự là cái thứ một người kia muốn Chứ
không phải là cái thứ mà ông muốn người
ta sẽ như thế nào
có nhiều người chúc người kia là có
người yêu
béo lên có người cho tôi béo lên có
người chúng tôi kiểu cưới sớm Mẹ hãy cái
gì đó tôi lỡ Chào mấy ông kia chúng ta à
em
có người chúc tôi ở kẹo dạng là sự
nghiệp ổn định hơn đấy vân vân Thế là
tôi không thích mày Cái đấy thì thành ra
cả lời chúc đấy thằng e nó hơi bị áp Đạt
cho bé uống thuốc ở thở ra là nên là
số 1 là một lá trúc kiểu ở
Vì theo như tôi nghĩ nó sẽ phải Trúc từ
tận đáy lòng hay là kẹo Chúc cái thực sự
ở cái người kia muốn hơn hơn hơn là chúc
cái À mà Minh muốn thì thôi thế
à à
Ừ
nếu mày ơi nếu ông nào cũng được đôi
chút để tôi thần trúc và kiểu hạnh phúc
và vạn sự như ý và
kẹo lạc quan Nói chung là theo kiểu tích
cực thôi chứ tôi không chúc phải ghi ở
cuộn đứng nha Chúc cụ thể cũng hay nhưng
mà ông phải thực sự hiểu Ngoài đấy muốn
gì thì ông ấy giúp chỗ này chúc một
người mà biểu người ấy chưa muốn lấy
chồng chúc người ấy lấy trông có có có
con mới có chồng sớm thì cái đấy làm
chưa ông thích điều đấy người ta không
thích chồng ăn à
à à
à Xong rồi bạn sự Nhi ăn chị mọi thứ đều
nhưng mỗi thứ mình muốn này nó sẽ ra nó
là chung chung nhưng một thời gian thì
bời chính thì chung mình không hiểu ở
người ta đây mình nên trực tiếp chúng
chung được thế chúc cụ thể lại hơi toàn
toàn đúng ạ
ở đấy thôi mình đại khái nói qua với
phải thế như thế thôi bạn Bộ hôm nay
hiểu nhỉ Chào bạn nhé
ừ ừ